mi spiace ma purtroppo non lo so ottimo
ciao a tutti i dottori e oggi nuova
challenge con les mystere box ecco in
siria grandissima richiesta visto che
l'altra solenne se vi è piaciuta
tantissimo quelle questi ride si leva la
vita di porta e ci avete consigliato poi
di fare siri contro google scelga la
mistery box tiri più brava di google o
se google è più bravo di siringhe cosa
ci farà scegliere non lo so perché come
sempre queste mistery box ci sono
ingredienti fantastici e ingredienti
terribili però questo molto se un
ingaggio da allora in questo mister i
box piccoli nervosa anche sembrano dei
contenitori di mini torte rosa c'è
sempre un ingrediente bello quindi
queste sono tipo il sogno ci saranno in
ogni turni se ci capita una questo
sappiamo già che avremo un super
ingrediente quindi speriamo che sirigu
gol e sceglieranno nostra tesi via basta
c'è mica sempre questi giorni perché c'è
in siria e io sono senza l'assistenza di
google
e allora vi consiglio di disattivare
assistente perché insomma si attiverà
con tiro lazio a vedere questo video
lasciato un bel live se volete vedere
altre sale slime viste ribot
consigliateci magarini commenti quali
altre fare qualche situazione di fiumi
lasciare un corista e andremo a farle
sembra diviso i comodi prendete i pop
corn lasciati be like hell broke inizio
vediamo carta farris e tasse come vedete
jolie sta al centro quindi zone sarà il
numero due
vediamo carta forbice sul tavolo di più
numero da 1 a 3
[Musica]
kabul ma allora per una corretta di cosa
stelle ti prego master rosa mente non è
rosea
cioè un certo non c'è un intento bello
che siri segno un numero tra 1 e 2
cosa ho trovato cercando sei single
allora giovinco si fosse duro segno il
numero accanto
2 mi spiace attiva poi qualcuno quello
detto che volevo solo far notare questo
vi diamo mai timore di un numero a caso
tra uno e due secoli si è scelto il
jolly anche se mi fa arrabbiare è che
scatta prima su due è un bello allora il
colore ad olio color rosa che fortuna
che fa vinse comunque fortuna perché mi
prenderò un mio online scena di colore
rosa che fortuna vediamo il mio
abbiamo un pigmento e giallo e il
colorante giallo quindi oltre intera
giallissimo che bello ed ora è giallo
magari voi perché blu no a dare un pò
settore così sfigato 9 caramia giallo
che blu e diventare verme 19 il secondo
il terzo
vediamo come diventa è ancora chiuso
guarda a questi avete visto il nostro
altro video in cui facciamo lascia lenze
tre colori con le tinte ad olio avrete
visto che è bellissimo effetto fanno
noi abbiamo provato proprio la colata
spalle tenuta con loro bianca fini
vediamo abbiamo chiamato la colla bianca
come verrà fuori
io credo che questa mia
anche qui un pochettino dei fili dei
fili tipo ma non è molto forte per
un'azione format già mi piace il mio
slime vinceti blue team celano vediamo
l'inter è bellissimo finora siamo stati
fortunati che strano
ecco qual colorante giallo e poi
mettiamo il pigmento venuto vediamo un
po come diventa giallo ovviamente forse
il pigmento fa un effetto metallizzato
bellissimo un po ho avuto un pò dorato
wow
mi piace tantissimo ancora ben definita
la più bella gialla o rossa di un altro
rosa e beni prima questo risotto allo
zafferano con questo bellissimo con
questo bellissimo slime bortolami a
sembra crema pasticcera avremo
pasticciona anche buona
dove round carta forbice strazio
piattaforme speriamo che si arrivi a 36
un numero tra 1 e 3
ok su kakà per quello che sono trovato
su internet su series and irish egli un
numero tra 1 e 3 oppure abbiamo sempre
andiamo se ti porterà fortuna bravissimo
questa cosa mi vuole bene allora dài
ok google di un numero tra 1 e 3
sì subito no blu no blu no blu non più
fortuna male allora c'è un pigmento e
colore bronzo e ti confronto ha parlato
vista non insisterà con crema e pronta
stitzer a te che cazzo fai vedere allora
sappiamo di bello il lavoro e di brutto
è che quando diventa rossa e verde
grigio
allora vediamo come diventa con questo
pigmento che scrivete nei commenti se tu
vuoi che colore rosa perlato di un pò
rosa antico bello
si chiama secondo me il giallo se lo
mangia non lo fa più vedere
è un pochettino si vede sta per
diventare marrone o da farti diventare
color senape guarda un altro no perché
c'era ovviamente però non è male dai
simboleggiante questa cosa scuri già ora
al mio rosa bellissimo se andiamo a
mettere questi glitter dorati voi
e poi basta polo giro per mettere il
carattere con certi che vettel è
indicata anche per comandare i sessi la
formativa come si rovina che però
secondo me non si rovina
mettiamo tre gocce di colorante o una
due tre bellissime sempre di metterle
tale ma perché tu non la metti tanto
quindi una prigione utilizzo potevo
farlo diventare rosso attiene perché
coloranti a doni sono furti simonato che
[Musica]
vediamo se questa volta 61 se questa
volta sceglie uno non proprio fortunato
così neanche tanto quello è confuso
sbaglia se la piega tempo fritta vediamo
trovato su internet
siri no no al numero a caso tra 1 e 3 a
giusy marito registro certo la sola
verde
speriamo bene vediamo la mia assistente
google che mi diceva ad accenderla bene
[Musica]
non scegliere un bye giorni
strano dunque
ma è bravo che il grigio capitale però
non è così brutto dai numeri già questo
non vi piace a tutti a pezzi dopo dello
slide sono dei glitter budan subatomica
scatola tra l'altro di allora mettiamo
il grigio
come diventerà che riesce a bellissimo
adesso non penso proprio oro
metallizzato
non mi dire che diventa grigia la
formalizzazione crateri e tu hai beccato
la mia perché si perde lo slime crema
pasticcera andata male ma ora
aggiungiamo un altro ingrediente che si
stanno malissimo lo stesso allora in
teoria possono mettere quello che voglio
io nonni ma come tutti parà dal prato
verde e argento sono tantissimi era così
bello e colorato guarda diventato
rientra invece il mio è sempre sempre
più bello con questo rosa adesso ci
aggiungiamo questi glitter blu che sono
ultra belli ma chissà che i posti salva
con i glitter piu si salva è già
bellissimo
guarda che bello è capito il calar è da
un anno che bello
che bello e l'inter sembra che facciano
tipo il pallino della fragola ma il
fragoroso che fortuna penultimo turno
questo perché sia aperto quello che
qualcuno vuole scappare la testa allora
la sfortunata partita finì 6 1 vantavano
e 3 non so se ho capito bene
sempre se rizzoli series e antipatica
parola su google a noi o che google
dimmi un numero tra 1 e 2 possibilmente
quello che vuoi tu chi vuol dirmi un
numero tra 1 e 2 1
allora prima prima io perché avrà più
fortuna rosa speriamo che diventi non
vuoi cambiare giorgia per cui copiato ma
non so se diventerà la rosa con questo
miscuglio e poi più mettere il mio nome
toniolo fortuna dubitare ha beccato in
colorate rino dice tra grigia per il
cavallo allora mettiamo il colorante
rosso storico che lo store di anche se
un po esuberanza perché ma secondo me
non piace a salvarlo
vediamo cosa sta diventando a marina o
di un colore un po strano però
effettivamente come arriva ciliegia
non posso scaduta comunque quello che
l'ha rovinata cpu sono quei glitter
maledetta è un po strano del circolo re
vediamo che il corpo a vostro favore
spiccano scusata e ammuffita sarebbe
primo ruberemo che lo migliori di
diametro il lotto a un pochettino la
miglior a 8 dai almeno il colore non è
più bruttissimo come prima allora io io
ve lo dico io metto solo una goccia di
taranto ha detto 2 cura capiterà al
meglio di uno guarda colorante rosa
arriva ancora fortissimo lo scienziato
da park grigio pd è vero e rimane libero
amore ad olio è imbattibile
rimane sempre in piedi ma adesso ci
mettiamo pure i glitter la prima perla
del tuo non è statico via beccate loro
idoli gelosa mentre sei fortunata però
riescono degli ingredienti imbruttimento
m io sono sfortunato con le scatole ma
aprendo delitti dietro impedito turno
abbiamo tutte le scatole rimanenti che
sono quattro vediamo quale beccheremo mi
era per sempre la slide
e vero che google per traore 4 subito
[Musica]
[Risate]
cioccolato mi sembrarono da una parte ei
sei un numero tra 1 e 3 trovato su come
far capire sempre si chiede sei un
numero potere scegli un numero tra 1 e 3
quindi ecco grande
allora cominciando dai ecco che cos'è
andiamo al quale altro blu e questo
bellissimo come si chiama pigmentazione
altro sito web
nell'altra camera questo bellissimo
romanzo di nostra che colore uscirà un
blu anche per il ruolo che adori è
talmente forte che aresino qualsiasi
altro fuori abbiamo speriamo che lo
giusto allora questo albergo
il primo è il primo appello agli altri
due ma che sfiga è all'ultimo turno
allora fortunatamente mi è capitata la
schiuma tabella fu affondata
il primo l'inter vere di questa volta
che la maledizione del vero il mio video
abbandonate preghiera vabbè ma quello
più bello l'ultimo ingrediente marrone e
marrone in video colorante ad ore il
colorante ad olio è più forte di tutti
la russia marocco
da allora
ma niente tutto colorato e blues
vogliamo che diventi di grigio o
qualcosa del genere gocce di blu che
abbiamo appena messa edilizia per carità
perché questo questo sud line per
fortuna è incredibile il colore orgoglio
viola non si impasta pro sky uno 1 si no
wow che bello che è il mio viola me
l'aspettavo
il rosa ha resistito al mero ma mi piace
blue bell aspetto devo mettere ancora il
mio secondo ingrediente che questo
pigmento celeste che superbello
altissima
quando morì eventi sono stati gli
ingredienti perché il nero messo poco
quindi prendere le box giuste non vuol
dire niente perché poi alla fine
potrebbe arrivati un marrone e verde che
rovinano tutto il mandato tipo color
salmone ora mettiamo innanzitutto la
schiuma da barba inter e brescia
almeno qualcosa di positivo st marrone
lo sapeva già che doveva diventare
marrone questo sla in bagno ho messo più
verde
tutto è nato tutto
ma ora mettiamo la cosa più bella che mi
sia mai capitata cioè il colore andrea
d'olio quindi di parole marrone vediamo
un po di cacchetta che è brutto perché
carica ne vediamo si deve solo
mischiarsi adesso ecco vedi ora mamma
mia è orribile comunali gomma ciancicato
ragazzi la mia via ora basta alle pere
che bello che bello chiamato ora andiamo
ad attivarli fine come potrete votare
chi vince va dall aspetto in base ai
suoni smr stiamo fronti brena
[Musica]
ecco qual è il mio slime allora il
colore molto particolare non riesco
neanche a capire che coloristi
esattamente una sorta di marroncino ocra
e il colore non è granché sentiamo un po
di suoi
[Musica]
quindi questo è il mio slide scrivete
nei commenti secondo voi che cos'è
questo è un marrone o un opera o beige o
grigio vuoto scrivete voi nei commenti
vediamo e ora vediamo quelle di vitale
per vedere uno slide fantastico un po
molliccio ma il sistema è un lilla
chiaro chi ebbe loro ma che bello è
perdente super estendibile bellissima
tutto glitter hoso basta neanche bei
colori bello per un colore violetto
league la si conosce la banda proprio
color lavanda
diciamo che è bello bellissimo non è
bellissimo bello allora dato che sapete
che dovete votare per me non solo perché
è uscito lo slime bello ma anche perché
ho vuoto l'italia è bello vederlo
obiettivo a fianco a fianco clown che
cos'è questa cosiddetta cui game
sappiamo corpo sembra latte e cioccolato
male che bello allora molto simili si
tenta il colore orribile il tuo
programma però da è bello da giocarsi un
morbido tra ragazzi votate ora qualche
vizio se vinco io servizi web che bello
che bel colore non può far perdere
quello della vita come il mio il calore
d'amore bellissima che iniziava tesi
sapere nei commenti che altri challenge
volete vedere e ora vi lasciamo fa
quando altrove le leggi qui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video challenge
video divertenti cliccate su quella che
preferiva la buona